So here's the reducer code. Let's step through it. We'll
start by setting up a couple of variables. Sales total,
which we'll keep the running total, is initialized to 0.
Because we haven't read any keys yet, old key starts at
none. Then we start reading from standard input. As with
the mappers we receive a line at a time that's tabbed
eliminated. In this case we expect a store name, a
tab, and one of the sales. So we'll strip out the
new line, separate the value and the key by
tab. That should give us two items which we'll store
in an array called data. If we don't have two
items, something strange has happened so we'll skip that line,
but that should never be the case. Because we know
that mappers send us the data in this format. For
the sake of clarity, we'll store the two items in
the array into variables. ThisKey will get the store name,
thisSale, the value. So here is the tricky part. We want to
know if the key has changed since the last row we
read. So we'll check if oldKey is even set, because if
it's not, then this is the first line we're reading. And if
it is, we'll see if it's different to the key we
just read in. If that's true, then the key has just
changed. In our example data, we had just switched from the
Miami row to the New York City row. So now we need
to write out the result. Which'll be key, which
is the store name, a tab and the sales total
for that store. Then we reset sales total back
to 0. Now for every row that we process, we'll
set oldKey to the key we are working on,
then add the current sale to the running total. And
then we'll loop back to the next row. Eventually, we'll
run out of data, which will take us out of
the loop. Do you think we're done?